>> Sean: FOX NEWS ALERT,
MONITORING THE SENATE G.O.P.
PRIMARY RACE IN THE COMMONWEALTH
OF PENNSYLVANIA, IT IS
TIGHTENING.
HERE WITH REACTION TO ALL OF
THIS IS THE AUTHOR OF THIS
INCREDIBLE NEW BOOK, "DEFEATING
BIG GOVERNMENT SOCIALISM," NEVER
THOUGHT IT WOULD GET THIS BATH
IS FAST BUT IT HAS COME A FORMER
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR NEWT GINGRICH.
WE HAVE A VERY TIGHT RACE.
IT IS FASCINATING, THIS RACE
COME OBJECTIVELY, ALL THREE
CANDIDATES TRIED TO CLAIM THE
MAGA MANTLE, ALL THREE RAN AS
TRUMP CANDIDATES.
'S GOT THE ENDORSEMENT BUT THEY
ALL WERE CLINGING TO THE MAGA
MANTLE, YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, NOT MUCH ROOM
IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY FOR AN
ANTI-TRUMP CANDIDATES.
I THINK JUST TO SURVIVE, PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO RUN SOMEWHERE IN
THE SHADOW OF TRUMP, MOSTLY
HOPING FOR HIS ENDORSEMENT,
WHICH OF COURSE DR. OZ GOT.
I THINK THERE IS ALSO A BIG
STORY ON THE OTHER SIDE, THE
DEMOCRATS IN NOMINATING
FETTERMAN ARE NOMINATING
SOMEBODY WHO IS A SELF-DESCRIBED
SENATOR SANDERS SOCIALIST, A MAN
WHO AS CHAIRMAN OF THE PAROLE
COMMISSION RELEASED AS MANY
CRIMINALS AS HE COULD AND FELT
THAT HE COULD NOT GET MORE
CRIMINALS OUT OF PRISON AND A
MAN WHO HAS PROMISED TO RAISE
TAXES ON VIRTUALLY EVERY
PENNSYLVANIA FAMILY, SO THE
CHOICE FALLS, WHOEVER WINS IN
THE PRIMARY IS GOING TO BE
EXTRAORDINARY STARK AND I EXPECT
THE REPUBLICANS ARE GOING --
TONIGHT, WHAT WE ARE SEEING SO
FAR IS MOSTLY WESTERN
PENNSYLVANIA, THAT WOULD BE
McCORMICK'S STRENGTH, AND WE
WILL SEE OZ GET STRONGER AND
BARNETTE GET STRONGER AS THE
NIGHT GOES ON.
THE BIGGEST SINGLE COUNTY FOR
REPUBLICANS IN PLURALITY IS
LANCASTER, AND LANCASTER HAS HAD
A MISTAKE AND HOW THEY COUNTED
THE RIGHT IN BALLOTS, SO THEY
MAY TAKE A DAY OR TWO TO
ACTUALLY REPORT.
IT IS CONCEIVABLE THIS WILL TAKE
A FEW HOURS TO SORT OUT, BUT I
THINK McCORMICK HAS DONE VERY
WELL, PARTICULARLY FOR NOT
HAVING BEEN ENDORSED BY TRUMP.
OZ HAS COME ON STRONG AND IN ALL
FAIRNESS, KATHY BARNETTE THE
LAST TWO WEEKS HAS HAD AN
AMAZING SURGEON FROM A POSITION
NO ONE WOULD HAVE EXPECTED.
HOWEVER WE NOMINATE I THINK IS
GOING TO BE SUCH A CLEAR
ALTERNATIVE TO FETTERMAN THAT WE
WILL ALMOST CERTAINLY KEEP THE
SEAT THIS FALL.
>> Sean: DO YOU HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THE NUMBER OF INCENDIARY
COMMENTS OF KATHY, TO ME, I
WOULD FIND THAT IN A GENERAL
ELECTION VERY DIFFICULT TO
OVERCOME BUT THAT IS ONLY MY
POINT OF VIEW.
>> I THINK THE GENERAL ELECTION,
IF SHE IS THE NOMINEE, THE
QUESTION WILL BE WHO IS MORE
EXTREME?
FETTERMAN HAS SO MANY THINGS
ALREADY ON THE EXTREME LEFT,
IT'LL BE A STRANGE RACE BETWEEN
TWO PEOPLE WHO EACH HAVE A LOT
TO DEFEND.
AGAINST EITHER McCORMICK OR
AGAINST DR. OZ, I THINK
FETTERMAN IS JUST TOAST.
EITHER ONE OF THEM I THINK WE'LL
BEAT HIM AND BEAT HIM PRETTY
HANDILY BECAUSE THE CHOICE WILL
JUST BE SO CLEAR.
I THINK OF THE TWO, FRANKLY,
DR. OZ IS STRONGER IN A GENERAL
ELECTION AND I THINK TRUMP'S
NOMINATION, AS WE SEE THE RURAL
COUNTIES COME IN, WE WILL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
REMEMBER, IN OHIO JUST A LITTLE
WHILE AGO, AS THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY WENT ON, SOME OF THE
CITY COUNTIES WENT FOR SOMEBODY
ELSE, BUT THE MORE SMALL TOWNS
AND MORE RURAL COUNTIES ALL WENT
OVERWHELMINGLY FOR THE TRUMP
CANDIDATE.
AND I THINK YOU MAY SEE THE SAME
THING HAPPEN HERE AS THE NIGHT
GOES ON.
>> Sean: WHAT DOES IT SAY,
DONALD TRUMP CAME INTO THE NIGHT
58-1 IN ENDORSEMENTS, NOW 75-1,
THAT IS A PRETTY GOOD RECORD.
>> WELL, THERE IS NO QUESTION
THAT WHETHER YOU LIKE TRUMP OR
DISLIKE TRUMP AS A MATTER OF
JUST HISTORY, NO MODERN
POLITICAL LEADER HAS DOMINATED
HIS PARTY OUTSIDE OF OFFICE ON
THE SCALE THAT TRUMP HAS, AND HE
HAS A FOLLOWING IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, HE HAS BROUGHT
IN AN ENTIRE GENERATION OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT REPUBLICANS
SIX OR SEVEN YEARS AGO, NOW PART
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, IT IS
AN AMAZING ACHIEVEMENT.
>> Sean: 51% OF THE VOTE IN,
STILL A LONG WAY TO